welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we're
discussing stimulants in particular
stimulants for the treatment of ADHD or
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
as many of you know there is tremendous
interest in drugs like Adderall Ritalin
Vyvanse and other stimulants as well as
non-stimulant prescription drugs that
have been shown to improve the symptoms
of ADHD such as modafinil or modafinil
and guanfacine today I'm going to
discuss all of these compounds in the
context of how they work to improve the
symptoms of ADHD I'm going to address
common questions about these compounds
such as are they just speed are they
similar to meth or Methamphetamine I'll
talk about their addictive potential as
well as their potential to cause
psychotic symptoms both in the short and
long term and of course I will talk
about the scientific literature
surrounding the most frequently Asked
question about these compounds which is
what are the long-term consequences of
taking any of them in childhood or in
adulthood now today's discussion centers
around the use of these compounds both
for childhood and for adult ADHD
but of course I'd be remiss if I didn't
acknowledge that there are a tremendous
number of people that use these
prescription drugs without a
prescription in order to improve their
ability to focus and indeed also use
them recreationally in fact some surveys
reveal that as high as 80 percent of
college-age young adults have used one
or several of prescription drugs such as
adderall Ritalin Vyvanse or similar at
some point and are doing so without a
prescription so they are either
obtaining those drugs from those that do
have prescriptions for them for ADHD or
they are obtaining them through Black
Market sources which of course carries
an additional and very serious risk
related to the so-called fentanyl crisis
that is as high as 75 percent of black
market drugs nowadays of various kinds
but certainly including the sorts of
drugs we're going to talk about today
are contaminated with fentanyl and
therefore are very deadly so today I'm
going to describe what these various
drugs really are how they work at the
level of neurons and brain networks and
how they change those brain networks in
ways that really can allow people with
ADHD to be able to focus better I will
answer the common question which is why
is it that giving children speed because
indeed several not all but several of
the compounds I'm going to discuss are
speed they are amphetamine why would
that cause a reduction in hyperactivity
if speed is a stimulant so I'll answer
that question for you and I will also
answer questions that are commonly asked
such as how these drugs impact things
like sleep hormone Health reproductive
Health as well as what is their impact
on height indeed it was one prominent
hypothesis that these ADHD meds could
actually restrict the height of children
I'll tell you whether or not that's
actually true or not and I'll discuss
the data surrounding whether or not
these drugs predispose people to
becoming addicts to other substances
even if people cease or continue taking
the stimulants that can help them in the
clinical sense for a ADHD before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Maui Nui venison Maui Nui venison is the
most nutrient-dense red meat available
Maui Nui spent nearly a decade building
a USDA certified wild harvesting system
to help balance deer populations on the
island of Maui the solution they built
turns the proliferation of an invasive
species into a wide range of
nutrient-dense products from fresh
butcher cuts and organ Meats to bone
broth and jerky I'm a particular fan of
their bone broth which has an unmatched
25 grams of protein per 100 calories and
I also love the ground venison and the
venison steaks talked many times before
on this podcast with expert guests in
nutrition who make it clear that we
should all be getting at least one gram
of protein per pound of body weight each
day with Maui Nui venison products
that's extremely easy to do and they're
extremely delicious as well if you'd
like to try Maui Nui venison go to Maui
venison.com huberman to get 20 off your
first order again that's Maui News
venison.com huberman to get 20 off
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Roca Roca makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are of the absolute
highest quality I've spent a lifetime
working on the biology of the visual
system and I can tell you that your
visual system has to contend with an
enormous number of different challenges
in order for you to be able to see
clearly Roca understands all of those
challenges at the level of the eye and
the visual system within the brain and
they've designed their eyeglasses and
sunglasses so that no matter what
environment you're in you can always see
with Crystal Clarity originally their
glasses were designed for sports and as
a consequence all of their glasses are
extremely lightweight and as well they
won't slip off your face even if you get
sweaty however despite being designed
initially for performance Roca
eyeglasses and sunglasses include a lot
of different styles that are designed
for you to wear to work or out to dinner
as well as the what I call the cyborg
style they're designed for cycling Etc
if you'd like to try Roca eyeglasses or
sunglasses go to Roka that's roka.com
and enter the code huberman to save 20
off your first order again that's Roca
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout today's episode is also brought
To Us by hvmn Ketone IQ Ketone IQ is a
ketone supplement that increases blood
ketones now most people have heard of
the so-called ketogenic diet but most
people including myself are not on the
ketogenic diet that is I and most people
eat complex carbohydrates fruits and
things of that sort in addition to
Quality proteins Etc it turns out that
even if you're not following a ketogenic
diet increasing your blood ketones can
still have benefits so for instance I
use Ketone IQ anytime I want to do
extended bouts of focused work preparing
for podcasts research writing grants and
if I ever want to exercise but I don't
have time to eat or I don't want to have
my gut full of food taking Ketone IQ and
thereby increasing my blood ketones
allows me to do cognitive work or
physical workouts without getting hungry
and with plenty of energy and cognitive
Focus if you'd like to try Ketone IQ you
can go to hvmn.com huberman to save 20
off again that's hvmn.com huberman I'm
pleased to announce that I will be
hosting two live events in September of
2023. the first live event will take
place in Toronto on September 12th the
second live event will take place in
Chicago on September 28th both Live
Events will include a lecture and a
question and answer period and are
entitled The Brain body contract during
which I will discuss tools and science
related to mental health physical health
and performance I should mention that a
lot of that content will have absolutely
no overlap with content covered
previously on the huberman Lab podcast
or elsewhere if you're interested in
attending either or both of these events
please go to hubermanlab.com tour and
enter the code huberman to get early
access to tickets once again that's
hubermanlab.com tour and use the code
huberman to access tickets I hope to see
you there let's talk about treatments
for ADHD and why stimulant treatments in
particular can be so effective
first of all it's long been known that
there are specific brain networks
involved in what we call attention now
attention is not one thing actually it
involves several different cognitive
operations including the suppression of
noise that is turning down the
background chatter in our heads and
turning down our attending to things
outside us like noises or visual cues
that are not relevant to what we want to
do and it also involves ramping up or
attending we're focusing on particular
things that are happening either in our
immediate environment or in our head or
both
so if that all sounds rather complex
indeed it is it involves several
different networks operating in parallel
but what we know for sure based on a lot
of clinical and scientific laboratory
data is that the so-called prefrontal
cortex the region of neural real estate
in your brain just behind your forehead
is critically important for
orchestrating which neural circuits are
going to be more or less active at a
given moment in order to bring about
what we call Focus or attention or task
switching or our ability indeed to
multitask because we can actually
multitask to some extent in fact if you
were to look at somebody and focus on
perhaps the expression on their face you
could do that while also attending to a
conversation that's happening nearby
it's energetically demanding it's hard
to do but we can do that that's actually
referred to as covert attention you're
covertly paying attention to something
else and then you can switch that
attention back to just one thing or one
small collection of things the point
being that attention is a powerful
resource it's what allows us to navigate
through life with efficiency and to be
adaptive in our behaviors it's what
allows us to learn and to build
relationships and have successful School
careers and professional careers and so
on but it is indeed expensive it takes
metabolic resources you know just at
rest if you were to think about
essentially nothing or whatever just
pops into your mind with no dedicated
effort toward paying attention to
anything your brain would consume about
25 of your daily caloric needs and then
when you lump on top of that your need
or your attempts to focus on things to
pay attention to specific things
should come as no surprise as to why
that often can make us feel tired as if
we've been working really hard and we've
been running a quote unquote mental
marathon when trying to learn and attend
to things it's hard work for the brain
and yet we can pay attention because of
that very precious real estate just
behind our foreheads the prefrontal
cortex now in people both children and
adults that have ADHD their prefrontal
cortex is not necessarily deficient in
any specific way except that it is not
as good at orchestrating the activity of
other brain networks operating in
parallel with it what do I mean by that
well if we take a step back and say what
is the prefrontal cortex really doing
the prefrontal cortex has this amazing
ability through what's called top-down
inhibition to quiet other brain areas so
for instance if you are feeling agitated
but you need to sit still your ability
to sit still even if it takes a bit of
work is coordinated by your prefrontal
cortex sending inhibitory suppressive
electrical signals to the networks of
your brain that are trying to generate
physical action in addition to that if
you are in a conversation that's either
a difficult one or a boring one or you
are tempted to interrupt and you are
actively holding back your desire to
walk away or to yawn or to blurt
something out
it's your prefrontal cortex that is
controlling that active suppression so
in many ways you can just think of the
prefrontal cortex as an Orchestra
conductor that is essentially saying shh
or not right now be quiet this is not
the time to many different brain
networks all at once
now in addition to that your prefrontal
cortex is coordinating with other brain
networks that are involved in generating
what's called salience or attention to
particular signals so the prefrontal
cortex in many ways is like a teacher or
an Orchestra conductor it can point to
in the neurochemical sense that is 0.2 a
given brain structure and say you I'd
like to hear more from you right now yes
you the student in the back speak up and
a moment later point to a collection of
small students chattering in the back
again I'm presenting all this by analogy
and say hey hey you guys quiet down
right now so and so is going to come up
to the front of the room and help us
work through this particular math
problem so when we hear that the
prefrontal cortex exerts what's called
executive function
what that refers to is the prefrontal
cortex's ability to quiet the activity
of particular neural circuits and to
enhance or increase the salience of
other neural circuits that are involved
in creating our Spotlight of attention
and what we know for sure based on many
many brain Imaging studies is that ADHD
is not necessarily A deficit in
prefrontal cortical function but rather
the prefrontal cortex's ability to
communicate with other brain areas in
the proper ways and so what results in
the brain of a person either young or
old with ADHD is that a lot of the
background chatter becomes very very
loud so for instance we have a brain
Network called the default mode Network
this is a fascinating brain Network this
is the brain Network that is active when
you just sort of sit in place and don't
think about much and then you start
having ideas about what you might do
next week it tends to be very
autobiographical so you might remember
an experience from the past you might
think about some of your desires some of
your dislikes this default mode Network
as it's called is also involved in our
imagination our in our spooling together
of different experiences that we've had
it doesn't tend to be the thing that's
really focused on anything external in
particular all at once
the default mode network is always
active but it's when we start to attend
to something especially things external
to us like it you know something written
on a page or a conversation or something
that we really need to learn something
we need to pay attention to that the
activity of the default mode network is
suppressed somewhat and that suppression
occurs not just by accident but because
the prefrontal cortex is actively
suppressing it
in kids and adults with ADHD the default
mode network is often still active at a
very robust level even while we're
trying to attend to things and that's
why someone with ADHD will sit down and
try and do some focused work and I'll
start thinking about something they want
or something they dislike their internal
state will start to distract them and of
course there are other networks in the
brain there's actually a what's called a
true salience Network there's the dorsal
attention Network there are a bunch of
different networks and brain areas but
again
when thinking about ADHD and especially
when thinking about how the drugs that
we're going to talk about today work to
alleviate the symptoms of ADHD
and in thinking about why so many people
use or even abuse these drugs for sake
of learning or recreationally we might
say
you start to realize that everything
centers back to the prefrontal cortex
and the prefrontal cortex's ability to
actively suppress and actively enhance
the activity of these multiple brain
networks including default mode networks
aliens Network dorsal attention Network
Etc
so rather than overwhelm you with a
bunch of names of brain areas and brain
networks today I'd really like our
discussion to focus on first what the
various drugs that are used to treat
ADHD are that is how do they work at the
level of neurons
second how they create a certain set of
conditions that allow their prefrontal
cortex to be a better conductor
third how that can be leveraged during
development to actually teach the
prefrontal cortex of a young child to
learn to be a better conductor because
that's really the Hallmark of the use of
these drugs is to try and enhance the
activity of particular circuits to
create a sort of learning so that the
prefrontal cortex is much more efficient
at doing its job of conducting and then
fourth we're going to talk about the
various things that I think most people
out there ask about when they hear about
drugs like Adderall Vyvanse and Ritalin
Etc which is you know are they addictive
why are they addictive can one use them
briefly or even from time to time and
still be okay what if I use them as a
child and I don't want to be on them
anymore should I put my child on these
drugs Etc it is I believe only by
understanding the biology of how these
drugs work
and their potential both to improve
brain function but also some of the
dangers associated with these drugs that
one can really answer those questions
for themselves or for their children
okay so let's start with a very basic
but critical question which is why in
the world would amphetamines speed or
other stimulants improve the symptoms of
ADHD
that's so critical to answer because if
you think about it the prefrontal cortex
needs to coordinate the actions of these
other circuits
and so just increasing the amount of
activity in prefrontal cortex you can
imagine would create a state of hyper
Focus perhaps but actually that's not
the case if you just were to ramp up the
activity of prefrontal Cortex what you
would find is that somebody would become
even less efficient at paying attention
to what they wanted to rather they would
pay attention to whatever was presented
in front of them with laser focus they
would lock on to essentially anything
and that's not good one of the key
things about prefrontal cortex is that
it needs to be flexible it needs to be
able to pay attention to this then it
needs to be able to pay attention to
that then it needs to go back to paying
attention to the thing it was paying
attention to previously and so on and so
forth life that is an effective adaptive
life a good life consists of
self-directing one's attention most all
of the time so why would stimulants do
that well
almost all not all but almost all of the
drugs used to treat ADHD fall under the
category of stimulants or what are
called sympathomimetics
sympathomimetic refers to the fact that
we naturally have a component of our
nervous system called the autonomic
nervous system the autonomic nervous
system has two major components one is
called the sympathetic arm of the
autonomic nervous system has nothing to
do with sympathy has everything to do
with ramping up our level of attention
and arousal it is the so-called fight or
flight aspect of our nervous system or
rather it mediates fight or flight but
immediates a bunch of other things too
including sexual arousal including
excitement and focus about something
that we want to learn or somebody that
we want to learn more about or
remembering a phone number or anything
that puts us into a state of alertness
and focus
the other arm of the autonomic nervous
system is the so-called parasympathetic
arm of the autonomic nervous system and
that's often referred to as the
so-called rest and digest component of
our nervous system and yes it controls
rest indeed it puts us into sleep
and yes it's involved in digestion but
it's involved in a bunch of other things
as well including sexual arousal
including rates of digestion including
salivation including all sorts of things
that don't just have to do with resting
and digesting
the way to think about the autonomic
nervous system is it's a sort of seesaw
so it's always at a balance someplace
between either predominantly sympathetic
or predominantly parasympathetic but
both the parasympathetic and the
sympathetic arms of the autonomic
nervous system are always active all the
time it's not as if one is completely
active and the others shut off even in
sleep your sympathetic nervous system is
not completely turned off and even
during a panic attack your
parasympathetic nervous system is not
completely turned off
drugs to treat ADHD
which are fall under the category of
stimulants are sympathomimetics because
they trigger the release of
neurochemicals and the activation of
components of our nervous system that
very much resemble the activation of the
so-called sympathetic nervous system the
one that makes us more alert and more
aroused so that's why they're called
sympathomimetics and the word stimulant
refers to a general category of drugs
that are sympathomimetics now the most
commonly discussed sympathomimetic is
one that fortunately is not
prescribed for ADHD and that's
methamphetamine these days we hear a lot
about meth
meth which is methylated amphetamine is
an extremely potent sympathomimetic and
it has tremendous abuse potential
Believe It or Not meth or
Methamphetamine is actually available as
a prescription drug but it is used very
rarely because of its high abuse
potential and all the terrible things
that it can do in terms of
cardiovascular health in terms of oral
health right there's this stereotype
that meth users have very degraded teeth
and indeed they do there's a reason for
that related to how meth impacts the
brain and body I'm going to talk a
little bit about methamphetamine a
little bit later but let's just Place
methamphetamine high on the Shelf as the
most
potent sympathomimetic that's out there
because even though it's not often
prescribed for ADHD there are class of
compounds very similar to it that have a
very similar pattern of action
that is not quite as potent but that
leverages the same underlying mechanisms
and they are very commonly prescribed
for ADHD namely Adderall and Vyvanse so
first let's talk about Adderall and what
Adderall is Adderall is a combination of
what are called amphetamine salts
amphetamine salts refers to the fact
that there are two major forms of
amphetamine there's a d amphetamine or
dexoramphetamine and levo amphetamine or
L amphetamine so I'll refer to these as
D and L amphetamine and for you
chemistry-minded folks out there the D
and the L also refer to the fact that
there is a l left-handed version of the
molecule and there's a d or right-handed
version of the molecule
this is only important to understand
insofar as you know that the D and the L
forms of the molecule look very similar
but they're mirror images of one another
and yet they can have very different
actions in the brain and body so
Adderall is a three to one ratio of D
amphetamine to L amphetamine
you should know that L amphetamine tends
to be less potent in increasing certain
neurochemicals in the brain I'll talk
about which neurochemicals they are in a
moment then is D amphetamine so D
amphetamine is potent stuff not as
potent as methamphetamine but very
potent stuff
l-amphetamine a little bit less potent
L amphetamine tends to be the
amphetamine that increases blood
pressure and heart rate what we call
peripheral
effects because it happens in the
periphery outside the central nervous
system
peripheral effects like increased heart
rate increased blood pressure sweating
Etc
are mostly activated by L amphetamine
whereas D amphetamine tends to work
mainly on receptors in the brain and
therefore have effects mainly restricted
to the brain
now what are these effects that I've
been referring to
the major effect of Adderall and other
sympathomimetic stimulants is to
increase the activity of two
neurochemicals the first of those
neurochemicals is dopamine and the other
of those neurochemicals is
norepinephrine first off I want to be
clear that when I say norepinephrine I
could just as easily say nor adrenaline
because those are the exact same thing
and forgive me even though I wasn't the
one to name the same thing two different
things
I'll try and stay with norepinephrine
but I may say noradrenaline they are the
same thing there's a whole story as to
how they got named
two different things but it's the same
thing
the major effect of Adderall and other
sympathomimetic stimulants is to
increase
the transmission of dopamine and
norepinephrine so what does dopamine and
what is neuropinephrine well both
dopamine and norepinephrine are what are
called neuromodulators that is they have
the ability to increase or decrease the
firing patterns the electrical activity
of particular brain circuits
both dopamine and norepinephrine have
separate roles in creating certain
States within our brain and body but
they like to collaborate meaning they
tend to be released at similar locations
in the brain in order to deliver us to a
particular state of mind and or body
so if we were to take a look at just
dopamine we would find that dopamine is
released at sites within the brain and
increases the activity of brain networks
that for the most part lead to increases
in motivation Pursuit and to some extent
mood
if we were to look at norepinephrine and
where it's released in the brain it
tends to be released at many not all but
many of the same sites where dopamine is
released and the main function of
norepinephrine is to increase the
activity of neural networks that are
involved in attention and focus to
particular things in our environment
okay so think of dopamine and
norepinephrine as collaborators because
indeed they are
and actually they're very
neurochemically similar as well it
actually just takes one chemical
conversion to turn dopamine into
norepinephrine so they are very similar
they're like close cousins that work
together to help us achieve a common
goal that involves increased motivation
focus and alertness
so when we talk about attention in ADHD
or we talk about quieting the
hyperactivity or impulsivity of ADHD one
of the reasons why drugs that are
effective in treating ADHD are so
effective is because they increase
motivation focus and alertness and they
tend to do that at very focal locations
in the brain it's worth taking a couple
of minutes to think about how
sympathomimetics such as adderall
actually increase dopamine and
norepinephrine they do so by affecting a
couple of specific operations at the
so-called synapse what are synapses
synapses are the communication points
between neurons they're actually the
spaces between neurons but that's where
a lot of the action is when neurons as
we say are stimulating the next neuron
or activating the next neuron or
inhibiting the next neuron the word
neuron just simply refers to nerve cell
and so what nerve cells have is they
have a cell body that contains their DNA
and a bunch of other stuff they have a
long wire like process which is referred
to as an axon and at the end of that
axon there are a bunch of proteins in
there that do really interesting things
so for instance there are proteins down
at the end of the axon that package
neurotransmitter into little spherical
things that we call vesicles
those vesicles can fuse with the end of
the axon and vomit the contents those
neurotransmitters into the synaptic
cleft into that little space between
neurons and then if enough of those
neurotransmitters bind to receptors on
What's called the postsynaptic side
which simply means the neuron on the
other side well then the next neuron
will become active and then the signal
will propagate from one neuron to the
next now I just described that whole
process pretty quickly and I like to
think pretty simply but it actually
involves a lot of different protein bits
and some pretty complex Machinery in
order to make that happen
I don't want to over complicate our
conversation but what I will tell you is
that down in the synapse in the
presynaptic terminal
the neuron that is going to release
neurotransmitter there are what are
called Transporters which sit there and
suck up or suck back up
some of the neurotransmitter that's been
released
there are dopamine Transporters and
there are norepinephrine or
noradrenergic Transporters down in the
synapse
what Adderall does and what other
sympathomimetics do
is to inhibit or disrupt the action of
those Transporters and the net
consequence of that is that when
dopamine and or epinephrine are released
into the synapse more of it is allowed
to stick around and to binder receptors
on the postsynaptic cell
than would be the case if Adderall or
the other stimulant were not present in
the system so one way that Adderall
increases dopamine and norepinephrine is
by disrupting the activity of these
presynaptic Transporters for dopamine
and norepinephrine the other way that
Adderall increases dopamine and
norepinephrine is that it disrupts the
activity of a different piece of
Machinery in the presynaptic neuron
which is called a vmat the vesicle
monoamine transporter 2. if you really
want to get specific you don't have to
remember these names but what these
vmats do is actually really cool what
they do is they actually take whatever
transmitter has been brought back up
into the cell by Transporters and they
package it into those vesicles that are
then going to be released
by disrupting the Transporters that
vacuum back up some of the dopamine or
norepinephrine that's been released
and by also disrupting the packaging
of dopamine and norepinephrine into
vesicles themselves what ends up
happening is that there's a buildup of a
lot more dopamine and norepinephrine in
the presynaptic terminal so that when an
electrical signal travels down the
neuron now the total amount of dopamine
and norepinephrine that's released is
increased
okay so what's happening when you take
Adderall is that you're getting more out
of the dopamine and norepinephrine that
you're releasing and you're releasing
more dopamine and norepinephrine
altogether and there's a third mechanism
by which Adderall increases the amount
of dopamine and norepinephrine present
in synapses
and therefore can act on other neurons
and that has to do with disruption of
the entire network between these
different proteins
I'm not going to go into that in any
detail because it gets somewhat
complicated in terms of the cell biology
and some of the biochemistry down at the
tips of these axons but suffice to say
that Adderall is such an effective
sympathomimetic
that is it can increase dopamine to such
a great extent especially compared to
other treatments for ADHD because of its
ability to increase dopamine release and
transmission and therefore action as
well as noradrenergic release and
transmission and action down there in
the synapse and it's worth pointing out
that most of the effect of Adderall is
an increasing dopamine as opposed to
norepinephrine it does increase
norepinephrine but its major effects we
should say the major effects that have
made it such an attractive drug to so
many people both for the treatment of
ADHD and for people to take
recreationally or off prescription or
for sake of studying or work simply
because they want to focus more and
longer is because of its ability to
increase dopamine to such a great extent
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be in the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 now a
bit earlier I mentioned that L
amphetamine levo amphetamine is present
in Adderall but
at one quarter the amount of D
amphetamine okay so there's a little bit
of l-amphetamine and a lot of
damphetamine in Adderall many of you are
probably familiar with vivance Vyvanse
is a commercial name for what many
people think is extended release
Adderall but actually Vyvanse is not
extended release Adderall Vivant is a
drug in which the pharmaceutical
industry has taken one component of
Adderall just the D amphetamine
component and attached to it an amino
acid called lysine now the amino acid
lysine is a big amino acid and the
attaching of Lysine to D amphetamine
what we call vivance makes it what's
called a pro drug it actually can't have
any effect on its own but when one takes
Vyvanse and it's broken down in the gut
but to a greater extent actually in the
bloodstream the lysines are cleaved off
slowly over time and as a consequence
Vyvanse is basically timed release
dmphetamine this is important because I
think a lot of people think that
Adderall which again is D amphetamine
and L amphetamine and those two things
operate quite a bit differently at the
level of norepinephrine and epinephrine
and cardiac versus brain effects a lot
of people think Vyvanse is just slow
release Adderall but it is not what
vivance is is D amphetamine only but in
time release form and Vyvanse was
actually developed as a way to try and
get around or rather prevent some of the
abuse potential of Adderall and Other
Drugs that contain damphetamine
D amphetamine stands for dextra
amphetamine and in the 70s and 80s there
were a fair amount of movies and there
was a lot of trafficking and there was a
lot of criminal activity related to what
was called dexedrine dexedrine is pure D
amphetamine so if we're going to be very
direct if I were going to just frame
these things in the context of their
neurochemistry what I can tell you is
that vivance is time release dexedrine
it's not time release Adderall now just
because there were movies and reports of
criminal activity related to dexedrine
that doesn't necessarily mean that
dexedrine is not an effective and useful
pharmaceutical in fact vivance which is
Time released dexedrine has proved to be
very effective in the treatment of ADHD
for a lot of people and the reason for
that is this time release does indeed
prevent abuse in the sense that despite
people's many attempts from what I hear
to increase the rate of Entry of the
damphetamine into their system by either
snorting it or you know God forbid even
injecting it and things of that sort the
attaching of that lysine to damphetamine
really does slow the absorption so when
somebody takes Vyvanse and hopefully
people are taking it responsibly when
they take Vyvanse what they're really
getting is a slow trickle of
damphetamine into their system and
therefore a slow long lasting increase
in dopamine and norepinephrine and
indeed that's what happens the effects
of Vyvanse can extend over anywhere from
12 to 16 sometimes even 18 hours
depending on how quickly somebody
metabolizes it and I should say that
there is no way to predict how quickly
one will metabolize any of these drugs
except by trying them that's one of the
sort of downsides of the state of things
these days there's no blood test or
enzymatic test that will tell you
whether or not you're going to be a fast
metabolizer or a slow metabolizer and
that's why people just have to sort
through different dosages which we'll
talk about in a little bit they have to
sort through different types of
sympathomagnetics you know some people
try Adderall and they find that you know
the quick time course of Adderall or at
least quick for them of about six to
eight hours is just too fast and then it
wears off and they get into a slump in
the afternoon other people find that one
Adderall taken at six a.m will have them
going all day long and into the night
and it's just too much stimulation and
they need to come way way down in dose
or they need to think about other
sympathomimetics for ADHD and we'll talk
about what some of those other options
are a little bit as well so the
important thing to understand is that
Adderall is really Two drugs DNL
amphetamine vivance is D amphetamine
which is also called dexedrine but with
this time released aspect created by
lumping a lysine on there and you may
notice that I haven't mentioned one of
the major
drugs used to treat ADHD and that's
ritalin or what sometimes also called
Concerta depending on again the time
release forms Etc Ritalin was very
commonly prescribed for the treatment of
ADHD early in the days of using
sympathomimetics in order to treat ADHD
so for instance I went to college in the
early 90s so I started college in 93 and
I graduated in 98. it was one year in
there as a let's call it a transition
year I can recall hearing that Ritalin
was being prescribed for ADHD in kids
and I like many other people were
wondering what are the long-term
consequences of this going to be I also
like many other people was very
perplexed as to why a stimulant
sympathomimetic like Ritalin was being
prescribed for hyperactive kids that
will become clear in a moment but
we don't hear so much about Ritalin
nowadays and I think that's because
Adderall and Vyvanse and things like
them have become so popular for the
treatment of ADHD
it's worth noting that Ritalin is not
actually amphetamine
Ritalin is what's called methylphenidate
and methylphenidate Works in a lot of
ways that are similar to the way that
Adderall and Vyvanse work
but there are certain ways in which it's
different now Ritalin methylphenidate
does increase dopamine transmission at
synapses and it does so also by
inhibiting the function of that
presynaptic dopamine transporter that
would otherwise suck more dopamine back
up into the presynaptic cell
methylphenidate Ritalin
also disrupts the activity of the
noradrenergic transporter leading to net
increases in the amount of
norepinephrine at the synapse but it is
not as much a potent inhibitor of the
noradrenergic transporter and therefore
most of the effect of methylphenidate is
to increase dopamine at synapses a lot
of people don't realize this a lot of
people think that Ritalin is just very
short-acting Adderall and that's not the
case it is true that Ritalin at least in
its standard form tends to have a pretty
short half-life and therefore its
effects basically kick in about 20 to 40
minutes after taking it sometimes a
little bit sooner sometimes a little
later and they last about four to six
hours as opposed to the six to eight
hours typical of Adderall but Ritalin is
not short-acting Adderall Ritalin is
mainly increasing dopamine and to some
extent norepinephrine at synapses
whereas Adderall and vivance are
increasing both dopamine and
norepinephrine to a much greater extent
and for those of you that are interested
in the underlying cell biological reason
for that it has something to do with
ritalin's relatively lower affinity for
the neuroadrenergic transporter but it's
also because remember I listed off three
mechanisms by which Adderall
and by extension Vyvanse increased
dopamine and norepinephrine transmission
right disruption the transporter
disruption of the vmat2 as well as a
disruption of the whole kind of complex
of communication between those proteins
well Ritalin is really only tapping into
the Drug's ability to disrupt the
dopamine and noradrenergic transporter
so it's three mechanisms of increasing
dopamine and norepinephrine for Adderall
and Vyvanse
and by extension dexedrine and it's only
one mechanism for Ritalin to increase
dopamine and norepinephrine and therein
mostly dopamine so if we take a step
back for a moment from all these drugs
and all this cell biology of neurons and
so forth
and we go back to the brain networks
involved in attention remember the
orchestra model or the teacher model
where the prefrontal cortex really sits
in top seat in terms of coordinating the
actions both the quieting and the yes
please speak
actions of the brain really bringing
about what we think of as focused
attention and task switching all the
stuff that goes along with learning and
focus and cognition well
what we know is that dopamine and
norepinephrine which are differentially
increased by these different drugs that
we've been talking about
also differentially impact
the various aspects of executive
function of the prefrontal cortex
increasing our attention for specific
things and while there is a lot of
nuance in the literature about this we
can safely say a couple of things first
of all
increasing dopamine at particular
synapses and networks in the brain can
serve as what's called noise reduction
it can help further enhance the quieting
of all that background stuff that
background stuff can be attention to
things in your environment like noises
or visual cues it could be some internal
narrative that you had about yesterday
or something that somebody said about
you or something that somebody you like
would like to say about you or whatever
it might be that's happening in your
head that's distracting you as well as
your representation of your internal
bodily State what we call interoception
this is a really important aspect of
attention that we don't often hear about
which is that we have the ability to
attend to things outside of us which is
called exteroception as well as
an ability to attend to things inside of
us which include things like thoughts
but also includes you know for instance
how empty or full our gut feels whether
or not we're comfortable in our chair
you know when we think about the
practice of focus and learning or
focusing as a verb
it involves often forcing ourselves to
sit still it often involves us
suppressing the fact that our foot is a
little bit cramped or that we might need
to use the restroom for you know we
might want to delay that for 10-15
minutes even though it might be fairly
urgent all these sorts of things
are Central to our ability to attend and
focus and so dopamine while it does many
different things in the brain many many
different things one of its main
functions in the context of all this
prefrontal cortex and attention stuff is
to quiet the amount of noise that is it
helps the prefrontal cortex suppress the
signals that would otherwise distract us
into thinking about oh yeah I'm kind of
thirsty right now or I need to use the
restroom or I really want to make this
caller I really really want to pick up
my phone all of that stuff all of that
suppression that shh that quieting down
of all the background chatter related to
things external and internal to us in
our head and our body is greatly
facilitated by having more dopamine
present in the synapses that allow for
what we call noise reduction now in
parallel to that is norepinephrine
norepinephrine is released from multiple
sites in the brain and body but within
the brain there's one major site of
neurons that manufacture norepinephrine
and the name of that site is Locus
ceruleus it sits in the back of the
brain it's actually a relatively small
collection of neurons but they are very
very powerful they extend their little
axons their wires to multiple locations
in the brain and they release
norepinephrine at those locations so
think of them sort of as a sprinkler
system that originates from one very
focal location but that can sprinkle
norepinephrine at multiple locations in
the brain and the amazing thing about
Locus ceruleus and that sprinkler system
is that indeed the sprinkler system can
be pretty widespread where everywhere
there's a sprinkler head
somebody's getting norepinephrine but it
also can fairly focally release
norepinephrine at particular sites so
while in the context of today's
discussion dopamine is acting largely to
impart noise reduction
norepinephrine has the ability to boost
signals at synapses to increase the
amplitude and frequency of communication
between neurons and in that way in the
context of today's discussion
norepinephrine when released at the
particular synapses in the particular
brain networks that are related to
attention and learning is largely
serving to increase signal so what we
have in the context of a drug like
Adderall or vivance or to some extent
methylphenidate Ritalin does this as
well is an increase in dopamine and
neuro epinephrine that is leading to two
things both a reduction in noise a
quieting of the circuitry that we don't
want to hear so much from and an
increase in the signal of the networks
that we do want to pay attention to and
the net effect of that noise reduction
and Signal amplification is what the
engineers refer to as increased signal
to noise and the consequence of that is
a heightened subjective sense or ability
to decide what we want to focus on sit
down or stand there and just focus on it
so the way that we've been discussing
drugs to treat ADHD and their ability to
increase dopamine and norepinephrine and
thereby to reduce the amount of noise so
to speak in the brain and to increase
the amount of signal related to things
that we want to attend to all presumes
that the amount of dopamine and the
amount of norepinephrine that's being
increased is perfect for what we want to
accomplish which is increased focus and
reduced hyperactivity and impulsivity
but of course in the real world that's
not always the case depending on the
dosage of the drug one sensitivity to
the drug even what stage of development
across the lifespan a person is at
things can really go Haywire pretty fast
and what I'm referring to when I say
Haywire is if you think about dopamine
and its ability to reduce noise well
dopamine does a bunch of other things as
well and in fact we know that if
dopamine is increased too much in the
brain somebody that has ADHD or somebody
that doesn't have ADHD people can become
euphoric people can become manic people
can even become psychotic likewise if
norepinephrine is increased too much
people won't just become alert they will
become very anxious have panic attacks
and depending on the drug they're taking
they may even experience very serious
peripheral symptoms meaning elevated
heart rate and sweating that is super
uncomfortable and on and on so
everything I've been discussing up until
now is true but I want to make it clear
that it's true in the context of
appropriately dosed prescribed drug for
a given condition which leads us to the
next question which is why would it be
that giving these drugs which are in
fact stimulants why would that calm a
kid down why would that common adult
with ADHD down and the answer to that is
not completely straightforward and it is
worth pointing out that not everyone
with ADHD has impulsivity and
hyperactivity and therefore an inability
to focus some kids and adults with ADHD
do have challenges with impulsivity and
hyperactivity some do not some just have
challenges with focus and I did an
entire episode about ADHD and we are
going to have an expert guest on this
podcast who specializes in the treatment
of ADHD to talk about some of these
issues further but I just want to remind
everybody that
as in the general population children
and adults with ADHD are capable of very
concentrated periods of focus
the pattern however tends to be that
children and adults with ADHD have a
harder time getting into that state of
focus and perhaps most importantly they
have a very hard time getting into a
forced state of focus for things that
they don't enjoy doing I'm sure many of
you are also thinking wait I don't like
to do certain things and it's harder to
focus on those things than on the things
I like of course does that mean I have
ADHD and the answer is not necessarily
so
kids and adults with ADHD exhibit an
extreme variation in their ability to
focus such that if there's something
they really really like doing they can
indeed Focus however for many many other
activities that are required in order to
develop I guess we'll just call it
normal life advancement so sitting still
listening to conversations that we may
not be particularly interested in that's
where the challenges come about so the
point is that these brain networks and
these neuromodulators like dopamine and
norepinephrine that we've been talking
about in Fairly straightforward terms
as it relates to a Drug's ability to
increase their transmission and
therefore an improved ability of focus
presumes two things it presumes that the
dosing is right that is that the levels
of increases in these neuromodulators is
just right and I also just want to
acknowledge that ADHD is first of all
not an inability to focus at all it is
immense challenges in focusing on lots
of different things as required for
normal life progression and it's also
the case that there is no one specific
pattern of ADHD that applies to everyone
with ADHD some people both kids and
adults will exhibit the hyperactivity
but not the impulsivity although those
two things tend to go hand in hand some
people will have a challenge in focus
without hyperactivity impulsivity and so
forth and all this just really speaks to
the complexity of ADHD and yet and yet
we can confidently say that there are
more drugs to treat ADHD than any other
psychiatric condition we've talked about
a few of those now but among those
Adderall vivance Ritalin also called
methylphenol State there are time
release versions there are
different variations on those time
release versions there's even straight
dexedrine which is prescribed for ADHD
in some cases and on and on and you
might also find it interesting to know
that that very large kit of drugs all of
which at least the ones we've talked
about so far are sympathome addicts or
stimulants
are more effective
at treating ADHD than are any other
collection of drugs for treating other
psychiatric disorders so what all of
that diversity of symptomology and ADHD
as well as
differences in sensitivity to drugs and
individual variation what all of that
speaks to is that the large kit of drugs
that's out there is designed to be
assessed with the careful consult of a
very qualified psychiatrist in order to
allow the child or adult to arrive at
the specific drug and the specific
dosage that's ideal for their particular
pattern of ADHD and that issue actually
gives rise to the answer to that now
somewhat age-old question as to why
giving stimulants to a kid that is
hyperactive would calm them down and the
answer is that the hyperactivity
impulsivity and focus issues present in
ADHD in children and adults are the
consequence not necessarily of deficient
activity of neural circuits in the
prefrontal cortex or deficient activity
of the default mode Network or deficient
activity of the salience network Etc
what appears to be the case based on a
lot of high quality neuroimaging data is
that the brains of children and adults
with ADHD have all of these networks
functioning but those networks are
actually hyper connected that is they
tend to be co-active at times when
ordinarily meaning
kids and adults without ADHD they would
not be co-active
so that's an important point because
it's easy to get the impression that
ADHD is just a deficiency in dopamine
and norepinephrine and that's simply not
the case if you recall dopamine and
norepinephrine are neuromodulators they
modulate the activity of other neural
circuits and they can both increase and
decrease activity within those circuits
so you don't necessarily want to think
about dopamine and norepinephrine just
as molecules that increase neural
activity and you certainly don't want to
think about ADHD it's just a deficiency
in dopamine or deficiency in
norepinephrine the way these drugs work
when they are used effectively to treat
ADHD is to tune the amount of dopamine
and norepinephrine that are present in
particular brain networks in order to
allow the person to arrive at just the
right balance between the activation of
these different neural circuits causing
them largely to be less synchronous in
their firing so this takes us back to
this question why giving stimulants to a
kid would calm them down it's not so
much that you're giving a stimulant to a
kid to place them into a state of calm I
think that's a common misconception
rather by increasing dopamine and
norepinephrine these drugs yes increase
levels of overall autonomic arousal they
are after all sympathomimetics but more
importantly to the treatment of ADHD
symptoms you are activating the
prefrontal cortex in a way that allows
it to be more of a coordinator of that
Orchestra conductor or if you prefer the
analogy to a teacher in the classroom to
ramp up the activity of certain neural
circuits in a given moment and quiet
down the activity of other neural
circuits such that the default mode
Network can still perform its incredible
actions after all the default mode
network is involved not just in
self-referencing and kind of daydreaming
but also creativity and Imagination
that's been well described in the
literature as well as the salience
network and these other networks that
are designed to drop us into very narrow
trenches of attention
these drugs for the treatment of ADHD
are are indeed stimulants but the goal
of prescribing these drugs to a child or
adult with ADHD is to adjust dosage
timing and the duration over which
somebody takes it in their lifespan in
order to allow those neural circuits to
work in the proper way meaning for the
conductor to activate the instruments in
that little symphony or band in the
appropriate order in order to arrive at
the right music as opposed to all the
instruments playing at once which would
just be complete noise or if again if
you prefer the classroom teaching
analogy for the teacher to call on one
student while the others are quiet and
then to call on a different student have
one student return to their seats to
have the students work in small groups
again all of this by analogy
the point being that dopamine and
norepinephrine are all allowing these
networks to be activated to the
precisely correct levels and in the
precisely correct sequence now the other
key aspect of drugs like Adderall
Vyvanse Ritalin and similar to tree ADHD
has everything to do with these
neuromodulators dopamine and
norepinephrine but it has to do with
their other incredible feature besides
just their ability to reduce noise and
increase signal Within These brain
networks and that incredibly important
feature is what we call neuroplasticity
or the brain and nervous system's
ability to change in response to
experience I've done entire episodes of
The huberman Lab podcast on
neuroplasticity what it is and how to
access it at different stages of
development and in adulthood by the way
you can find those episodes at
hubermanlab.com by simply searching
plasticity in the search function but
the important thing to understand about
plasticity in the context of today's
discussion is that while there are many
different ways to induce neuroplasticity
almost all of them almost all of them
involve
strongly activating certain brain
Networks
and in that case also strong or elevated
release of certain neuromodulators
now we've talked about dopamine and
norepinephrine they are but two of many
neuromodulators others include serotonin
acetylcholine and each of the
neuromodulators does different things
that different synapses in the brain and
there's some Global statements that can
be made about each of them we've made
some of those earlier like dopamine is
broadly involved in motivation craving
and pursuit and norepinephrine and
Signal detection and drawing of focus or
salience to something in our environment
or in our body or inner experience
serotonin does other things
acetylcholine does other things but
what's really important to understand is
that any time there is a dramatic
elevation in dopamine and norepinephrine
relative to Baseline relative to what
was happening with dopamine and
norepinephrine just prior to that that
has a tendency to promote
neuroplasticity at particular synapses
so here is where it's appropriate to
remind everybody that neuromodulators
are different than neurotransmitters
neurotransmitters are chemicals that
just like dopamine and norepinephrine
are released between neurons and they
are what actually contribute to the
electrical signals going up or down
between different neurons and again
dopamine and norepinephrine modulate
that activity causing a given amount of
neurotransmitter to have an even greater
effect
for instance so when we hear about
dopamine and norepinephrine and we hear
about motivation or Focus Etc that's all
fine and good but it's also important to
remember that when dopamine and
norepinephrine are increased there is a
higher probability of strengthening
connections where dopamine and
norepinephrine are increased and what
that means is that later even if levels
of dopamine and norepinephrine are not
increased if they go back to Baseline
it's often the case that if in our prior
history or the history of a given set of
neurons in our brain there was more
dopamine or norepinephrine around
it's very likely that the connections
where that took place are strengthened
and therefore more easily activated and
this takes us back to the really
original purpose of prescribing the
sympathomimetic stimulants to children
with ADHD during development
it was yes
designed to try and help them Focus to
reduce their hyperactivity and help them
Focus but it was also designed to help
the brain networks that are responsible
for Focus to undergo neuroplasticity
that is for the synapses involved to
strengthen so that those networks could
function more efficiently later on even
after cessation of the drug this is an
absolutely crucial point that I think is
not often discussed when people for
instance say should I put my kid on ADHD
meds or should I take my kid off of ADHD
meds as they transition from adolescence
to their later teen years and into
college I mean after all no child or a
parent or adult for that matter wants to
achieve a bunch of benefits with a drug
and then lose those benefits later
nor does any parent or child want to
take a drug that they don't need to take
when they could access other routes to
improving the neural circuitry or the
function of some health system in the
body because I don't think anyone really
wants to medicate their kids unless they
have to I would hope not and I don't
think any kid wants to be medicated
unless they absolutely need to be
medicated so increasing dopamine and
norepinephrine with these drugs like
Adderall Vyvanse Ritalin and similar
is causing several things and some of
those things actually provide some
general answers as to whether or not
parents should put their kids on these
compounds in the first place obviously
they're going to do that in the under
the careful consult of a qualified
psychiatrist I would hope and only under
those circumstances but also whether or
not the child should stay on those drugs
over time
and here's what we do know for sure
I did a vast search within the
literature in order to arrive at what is
very clear which is that children with
ADHD true ADHD who are diagnosed with
ADHD and are treated with appropriate
doses of drugs like Adderall ritalin or
Vyvanse
they're far better both in childhood and
later in life when it comes to
Performance in school
performance in terms of focusing on
anything and in terms of General
outcomes so for instance a lot of people
have wondered and worried about whether
or not treatment with these drugs early
in life will set up a predisposition for
illicit drug abuse or craving an
addictive potential later and it is very
clear from the studies that have emerged
over the last really 15 years but mainly
within the last five years
that's when most of the data have
arrived that children with ADHD who are
not treated correctly both with drugs
and behavioral treatments because really
the combination of drugs and behavioral
treatments is the optimal situation
so kids with ADHD who are not treated
with drugs and behavioral treatments to
deal with their ADHD have a much higher
tendency towards illicit drug use and
addictive drug potential in their
adulthood okay so there is a real danger
to not treating ADHD during childhood
and the reverse is also true which is
that children with ADHD who take
prescription drugs that are
sympathomimetics so yes as you've heard
they are speed amphetamine is speed
although I should say if they take
Methylphenidate
ritalin or Concerta or something of that
sort that's not amphetamine nonetheless
it's a stimulant it's a sympathometic
also
these are kids that are taking these
drugs during development and therefore
levels of dopamine levels of
norepinephrine are being increased in
their brain and body and you might say
well wouldn't that lead to a craving for
these things later in life and that does
not appear to be the case in fact
there's some very nice neuroimaging
studies mainly positron emission
tomography studies that I'll provide a
link to in the show note captions that
show the early treatment with these
drugs actually leads to
combinations of increased dopamine
Transmission in the forebrain later in
life at a lower level or a lower
threshold I should say in a way that
essentially says there's normalization
of the circuits Across Time by the
application of these drugs early in life
again
in the case of children that have
diagnosed ADHD I in no way shape or form
want to imply that all children should
be treated with these drugs is quite
clearly not going to be a good idea so
all of this really speaks to the
critical importance of getting an
accurate diagnosis of ADHD you know
diagnostic criteria include many things
in children there are multiple there are
more than nine diagnostic criteria for
each of the categories relating to
impulsivity hyperactivity and so on so a
well-qualified psychiatrist will do
several things they will first of all do
a careful diagnostic evaluation of a
child and in addition one would hope
that they would think about prescribing
both appropriate pharmacologic
treatments for ADHD but also be aware of
and prescribe the various other types of
prescriptions meaning behavioral
prescriptions so there are clearly
certain learning tools and things that
kids can do in order to improve their
ability to focus and to be less
impulsive that combine especially well
with drug treatments as well as new
advancements in the realm of nutrition
and supplementation that are constantly
coming online and the best psychiatrists
are going to be tuned into all of those
aspects of treatment for ADHD not just
prescription drugs but also behavioral
treatments also nutritional guidelines
also supplementation and also updating
each and all of those things as a child
matures from each stage of development
to the next I'd like to take a quick
break and thank our sponsor inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
assessed with a quality blood test the
problem with a lot of blood and DNA
tests out there however is that they'll
give you information about certain lipid
markers or hormone markers but no
information about what to do with all
all of that data inside tracker makes it
very easy to look at your levels of
hormones metabolic factors lipids Etc
and then to assess what sorts of
Behavioral nutritional supplementation
or perhaps other interventions you might
want to use in order to bring those
numbers into the ranges that are optimal
for your health inside tracker's
ultimate plan now includes three new
hormone markers that are critical to
measure during a woman's reproductive
and menopausal years these are estradiol
progesterone and thyroid stimulating
hormone if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can go to insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off now
the other common question is if a child
has been treated with these ADHD meds
during development do they need to
continue on those drugs indefinitely and
the short answer to this is it depends
and that can be a somewhat frustrating
answer I realize but the good news is
it's something that can be assessed in a
fairly straightforward way
let's recall that the use of these drugs
to treat ADHD is designed to accomplish
two things it's designed to improve the
function of those neural circuits that
allow a child to focus and it's also
designed to increase the strength of
those circuits to effectively teach the
circuits how to learn what focus is in
other words these drugs are designed in
some cases to be used and then withdrawn
later because the circuits that they
helped build up are functioning well
in some cases however the circuits that
underlie Focus are not going to be able
to function at the level required for
normal healthy life progression unless
there's continued application of the
drug so how would this work in the real
world context well I think any child or
adolescent or person younger than 25
that's taken these drugs has no doubt
achieved some level of neuroplasticity
of the neural circuits related to all
the things we call Focus I and I want to
be very clear there's no single brain
area or set of brain circuits for what
I'm referring to as Focus
because after all Focus involves test
switching Focus involves all sorts of
different cognitive operations depending
on what we're focusing on
right the focusing on a sport is
basically a practice of directing one's
attention in different locations at
different moments focusing on studying
is an entirely different pattern of
focus altogether but the point being if
a person 25 years or younger takes a
drug that increases dopamine and
norepinephrine and assuming that things
are working meaning
the dose is right they're achieving
better ability to focus etc those
circuits are going to get stronger and
it seems entirely reasonable in fact it
was supported by the psychiatrist that I
spoke to prior to this episode that
people who've been on ADHD meds for any
point of time prior to 25 talk to their
psychiatrist about what tapering off
those drugs in order to examine whether
or not they still need those drugs would
look like now I mentioned the word taper
because there is a withdrawal potential
of Simply stopping these drugs very
quickly because they do ramp up dopamine
and norepinephrine
even though they increase plasticity of
the neural circuits for focus and mood
and motivation if one very abruptly
ceases taking any of these drugs
it does not feel good that drop in
dopamine that one inevitably experiences
is almost always associated with
lethargy with depressed mood with
feeling not good in a number of ways and
of course challenges in Focus so anytime
one is going to go off one of these
drugs or sample what it is to even
reduce dosage that has to be done in
close communication with a
board-certified psychiatrist at the same
time it was made very clear to me from
ADHD expert psychiatrists
that reductions in dosage over time
often are optimal for a patient okay and
this gets to the whole issue of dosage
generally you know I spend a good amount
of time talking to somebody who
prescribes these drugs both to children
and adults about dosage ranges and I
don't want to spend too much time on
this
from the perspective of how much one
should take in fact I don't want anyone
to think that what I'm about to say
should dictate what they should take
specifically because that's something
that really has to be worked out on an
individual basis but it is worth noting
that if you look at the studies on
Adderall and Methylphenidate
but you'll see it is a pretty broad
range
in those studies and that's because some
of the studies used people that were
already taking these drugs and asked
them to participate in neuroimaging
studies other studies actually put
people on these drugs for the very first
time or adjusted their dosage and so
you'll see a tremendous range of drug
doses explored for instance you will see
anywhere from 10 to 40 milligrams of
Adderall per day you'll see anywhere
from 10 to 60 milligrams of Ritalin per
day and here we could easily be talking
about studies on children or adults
with respect to Vyvanse you'll see that
the dosages tend to be much higher in
part that's because vivance has if you
recall it's that lysine which is a big
molecule stuck on D amphetamine which is
a smaller molecule and so the dosages of
Vyvanse tend to be in the hundreds of
milligram ranges but most of that 100
milligrams of Vyvanse is not going to be
the damphetamine it's going to be the
lysine which doesn't do anything in the
context of treating the brain it's just
there to control the slow release so
it's thought that 100 milligrams of
Vyvanse translates to roughly nine
milligrams of Adderall and on and on and
actually it's pretty hard to translate
between dosages of different drugs in
any direct way and in speaking with a
psychiatrist expert in ADHD in
preparation for this episode he made
very clear that it is extremely
extremely difficult to predict how a
child or adult will react to a given
dosage of any of these drugs so much so
in fact that he anecdotally reported to
me that one of his patients is a male 3
100 pounds diagnosed with ADHD and who
achieves tremendous relief from just 2.5
milligrams of Adderall per day
and at the same time he has two patients
both of whom are sisters so they're
genetically related who are in the 120
to 140 pound range who did not respond
well at all for the treatment of their
ADHD until their dosages were very very
high and if I tell you these dosages I
just want to warn you in advance I'm not
suggesting anyone explore these dosages
without of course the approval of their
psychiatrist turns out that neither of
these two young women responded at all
to ADHD medication until they achieved
dosages in the range of 180 in the case
of one sister and 240 milligrams in the
case of the other sister per day which
is an astronomically high dose on the
face of it but this physician again
board certified physician expert in
adiation
verified for me that indeed neither of
them experience any discomfort or side
effects that led them to not want to
take the drug
but of course that amount of Adderall
could send somebody else into an
absolute psychotic fit could potentially
even cause cardiac arrest I mean it's
remarkable the ranges of Adderall that
are used effectively in children and
adults and this is true for a lot of the
other sympathomimetics used to treat
ADHD and of course a good psychiatrist
will always assess
dosage as it relates to positive
benefits you know relief of symptoms so
relief of impulsivity relief of
hyperactivity improvements and ability
to focus
and of course they they are going to
consider side effects any uncomfortable
adverse effects that come from taking
the drug at a given dosage or taking the
drug at all now of course this all begs
the question of why such tremendous
variation is this due to genetic
differences in the amount of dopamine or
norepinephrine that people make it
appears that the major
underlying factor for why people require
such vastly different dosages of these
sympathomimetics for the relief of ADHD
has to do with the different enzymes or
levels of enzymes that people make which
metabolize these drugs both in the brain
and body and unfortunately there is no
simple blood test or saliva test or test
of any kind that can predict how someone
will respond to these drugs so the most
logical and safe way to assess dosage is
to start with the lowest possible
effective dose and to increase only as
necessary in order to achieve the
positive benefits while of course paying
attention to any side effects that might
arise a question that comes up from time
to time when discussing the long-term
effects of drugs like Adderall Ritalin
and vivance is whether or not they can
negatively impact height or growth or
development in some other way this is a
logical question to ask because after
all these drugs are effectively
mimicking stress in the body and most
everyone is heard by now that while
stress can help us in the short term it
helps us deploy immune molecules to
protect us against infection and it
sharpens our visual focus and our
ability to respond to things for
survival
chronically elevating our stress over
long periods of time we know reduces the
effectiveness of our immune system and
can actually cause certain forms of
brain degeneration and while there
aren't a lot of longitudinal studies on
the heights of kids with ADHD and of
course we never can tell how tall
someone would have grown to be if they
were treated with a drug because we
don't have a perfect control experiment
even in the case of identical twin
experiments and therein there aren't
that many of those examples where one
twin was treated for ADHD and the other
wasn't Etc but here's what we know it
does not appear that treatment with
sympathomimetics during development
provided that dosages are kept in the
appropriate ranges
is going to limit overall height in fact
if you look at the data it appears that
children with ADHD who are treated with
ADHD meds actually arrive at slightly
higher bmis body mass indexes compared
to age-matched peers now of course body
mass index doesn't necessarily correlate
with height right someone could not
achieve a full height but could be
heavier either through bone or fat or
muscle or combination of all three but
what we know is that the appropriate use
of ADHD meds during development is not
stunting development in any kind of
overall way it's not preventing
maturation of the body in ways that are
leading to reduced weight or somehow
impaired growth overall with that said
long-term elevations of sympathetic
nervous system activity does carry some
risk and one of the primary risks that
people have wondered about is
cardiovascular risk this makes perfect
sense right when you increase the
activity of the sympathetic nervous
system you increase blood pressure to
increase heart rate you increase in some
cases peripheral sweating you know all
the things that we associate with stress
so you can imagine that a child or adult
with ADHD that takes these
sympathomimetics every day even if the
dosage is kept in a Range that doesn't
allow them to experience any immediate
untoward side effects so they're not
feeling miserable they're just feeling
like they can focus better but one
always wonders what's going on under the
hood so to speak
there is as far as I know one major
study that's addressed this and the
conclusions of that study were a little
bit hard to put into a single category
it did point to a subtle increase in
cardiovascular risk
but the results did not point to
anything so dramatic that the authors of
the study warned against taking these
drugs or encouraging people to cease
taking these drugs again provided
they're being prescribed by a
board-certified physician for ADHD and
at the appropriate dosage for that
person that said I think this all again
speaks to the importance of arriving at
minimal effective dosage and it stands
to reason that if you're somebody who's
taking ADHD meds or if your child is
taking ADHD meds that one would want to
do all the other things that they could
do in order to try and improve
cardiovascular health or at least not
put it at additional risk so those are
going to be the obvious things like
avoiding smoking or vaping nicotine
regular exercise is going to be
encouraged and things of that sort and
that dovetails into a bunch of other
questions that are often asked anytime
the topic of Adderall or Ritalin comes
up which is what about alcohol you know
is drinking alcohol the same time or at
different times even going to be
problematic if one is taking these drugs
is taking benzodiazepines going to be a
problem etc etc
there's a very straightforward answer to
this which is it's very clear that
alcohol certainly in children but also
in adults is best not consumed I did an
entire episode about alcohol
which got into this and the data for
this if you've heard that having some
alcohol in particular red wine is better
for you than know alcohol that is simply
not true sorry it's not true most adults
who are not alcoholics can probably have
up to two that's right two drinks per
week and still be on the safe side of
Health although zero is better than two
and once you get past two you start
seeing effects on various systems
including increased cancer risk
especially brain
neuron loss and degeneration risk I
covered all of those data in the episode
on alcohol that you can find at
hubermanlab.com
combining alcohol with sympathomimetics
even though they reside in very
different Pathways within the brain in
fact the sympathomimetics are driving up
sympathetic nervous system activity
whereas alcohol is actually doing the
opposite it's depressing it and yet all
the data points to the fact that
combining alcohol with sympathomimetics
such as Vyvanse Adderall ritalin or any
kind of amphetamine is going to be more
detrimental to the brain and body than
simply taking those drugs on their own
put differently and more directly if you
are taking any of the drugs that we've
been talking about to treat ADHD or if
you just happen to be taking them for
whatever reason you are going to want to
avoid drinking alcohol at any time and
you're going to want to avoid
benzodiazepines and similar unless
they've been prescribed to you by your
physician in advance of this episode I
put a call out on social media for
questions about Adderall Etc and I got a
lot of questions about whether or not
their impacts of these drugs on the
hormone systems of the body and if they
impact the reproductive system in
particular I also got questions about
whether or not these drugs impact sexual
behavior or libido or anything of that
sort in reviewing the literature what I
can tell you is that there are very few
studies unfortunately of the long-term
effects of these drugs on the endocrine
or hormone systems of the body
but we do know a few things for sure
first of all when you increase the
activity of the sympathetic nervous
system for long periods of time you are
very likely increasing levels of
cortisol cortisol is a quote unquote
stress hormone but cortisol also plays
some really important positive roles in
your body in fact if you want cortisol
released especially early in the day you
don't want cortisol released so much
late in the day this actually relates
back to timing and schedules of taking
drugs this is something again that needs
to be worked out with your psychiatrist
or your child's psychiatrist but one of
the reasons why there are so many
different drugs for the treatment of
ADHD is that each and all of them has a
different time course of action so
Ritalin is very short-lived which might
sound bad because then you have to take
it multiple times throughout the day but
if you think about from the perspective
of sleep and the importance of having
low cortisol at night and these drugs
increase cortisol and the importance of
getting sleep because after all sleep is
the foundation of mental health physical
health and performance in kids and
adults it's responsible for growth it's
when neuroplasticity happens it's just
so vitally important
a lot of the drugs that we've been
talking about can severely limit one's
ability to fall and stay asleep and so a
short-acting drug like Ritalin is
actually attractive from the perspective
of being able to take it in the morning
and still get to sleep at night or
taking it in the morning and in the
afternoon and maybe even again in the
evening depending on the person
and then still being able to fall asleep
at night
whereas long duration release of D
amphetamine which is what you get when
you take Vyvanse
for some people is going to inhibit
their sleep they'll get a nice steady
rise and Improvement in focus and
reduction in hyperactivity but they
might have a lot of trouble falling
asleep at night and Adderall having a
somewhat intermediate time course of
action between ritalin which is
short-lived and Vyvanse which is very
long-lived
perhaps is going to be the best solution
for somebody else where they can take it
early in the day perhaps at a low dose
maybe again later in the day low dose
and then still fall asleep at night but
I've spoken to people and I've spoke to
this clinician expert in ADHD who told
me that some people will take as little
as 2.5 milligrams of Adderall at 6 00 am
and have a hard time falling asleep
later that night at 11 PM so again
vastly different sensitivities to these
drugs leading to vastly different
requirements of dosage and timing of
intake and which particular drug
somebody might choose to or choose not
to take so how does that relate to
hormones and sex and reproduction well
cortisol itself is a hormone it can act
as a bit of a hormone and a
neurotransmitter in the brain but for
the most part it's acting as a hormone
in the brain and body and it does a
number of things first of all it can
enhance your levels of focus and
alertness it can activate your immune
system I know that immunologists out
there just cringe when I say activate
the immune system your immune system is
always doing various things so it's
always active just as your nervous
system is always active but it can
to be specific it can amplify or
mobilize the release of
anti-inflammatory molecules in your
brain and body to combat different types
of bacterial viral and fungal infections
it's doing an enormous number of
positive things it's also involved in
setting mood it has interactions with
thyroid hormone pathways
I've done entire episodes about cortisol
and cortisol regulation
to paint all of that with a very broad
brush and briefly now it's advantageous
to have your cortisol release high in
the early part of the day and to taper
off toward the end of the day in fact
late day elevations in cortisol are a
strong correlate of depressive symptoms
this was demonstrated by my colleagues
David Spiegel and Robert sapolsky at
Stanford School of Medicine
but that is not to say that cortisol is
bad it's to say that the timing of
cortisol release is key so do these
sympathomimetic drugs
disrupt the endocrine system well they
can if you are very awake and very alert
regardless of whether or not you're
taking your sympathomimetic treatment
for ADHD early in the day or late in the
day you are very likely experiencing
elevations in cortisol late in the day
so it is important even for those of you
that like to study and need to focus in
the evening and nighttime hours that you
try and limit your levels of overall
alertness and certainly stress late in
the day because doing that day after day
after day for several weeks or months or
years can indeed disrupt other hormones
in the endocrine system and again that's
because cortisol is interacting with
thyroid hormone and testosterone and
estrogen in fact cortisol in many ways
competes with or can out-compete for the
production of testosterone and other
so-called steroid hormones remember
cortisol itself is a corticosteroid
hormone
so when we hear the word steroids
oftentimes people just think about
athletes and steroid abuse in sports but
steroid hormones includes a lot of
different types of hormones which are
good for us our endogenous steroid
hormones are vital for all sorts of
things Vitality reproduction Etc
and
the way this works in general terms is
that the cholesterol molecule is used to
create testosterone and cortisol and
estrogen
if we make too much cortisol we in many
ways are reducing the total amount of
testosterone that we make or that is
active it's not
exactly that straightforward but we can
make that statement with uh with
confidence for instance if you spike
your cortisol just briefly during the
day because you have some sort of
stressful event that's not going to
inhibit your testosterone in fact it
probably is going to boost your
testosterone levels somewhat however if
your cortisol levels are chronically
elevated yes indeed it's likely that
you're going to suppress your total and
or free Unbound forms of testosterone
and downstream to that you will
experience effects such as reductions in
libido reductions in muscle and bone
mass reductions in all sorts of aspects
of testosterone related psychology and
bodily biology this is true for both
males and females and the same thing
could be said for estrogen now what's
impossible for us to say is whether or
not taking a given treatment for ADHD is
going to for instance prevent a woman
from ovulating that could happen through
chronic elevations and cortisol but
there's no direct link meaning there are
no studies at least that I'm aware of
showing that people that take Adderall
have irregular ovulatory Cycles or that
they cease menstruating entirely I don't
think there's any evidence for that
whatsoever nor is there any evidence
that people that take Adderall or other
sympathomimetics for the treatment of
ADHD have lower overall testosterone in
fact you can imagine all sorts of
instances in which the opposite was true
that a child or young adult or adult who
has ADHD but then goes on these meds to
improve their symptoms is now focusing
and achieving more in life we know that
happiness can impact dopamine and vice
versa and testosterone levels and
productivity itself and reaching our
goals can feedback on the hormone system
so anytime there's a discussion about
hormones or a study that shows that
doing X or not doing why impacts hormone
levels of a given type we have to be
very careful to make sure that we're
talking about causality because all of
these hormones are in a very intricate
crosstalk with one another we can
however make a very general statement
which is that when you are in states of
stress for long periods of time that is
not a favorable condition addition for
your immune system your hormone system
or frankly any other system in the brain
and body so the treatment of ADHD with
these drugs should never be done at the
expense of these other critical
biological systems another common
question and concern is whether or not
kids and I suppose for that matter
adults that take medication for ADHD are
basically being predisposed to psychosis
and or other forms of addiction and
earlier we talked a bit about the risk
for addiction and the take-home message
there is very clear that kids and adults
that are treated for ADHD appropriately
so with the appropriate dosage of the
appropriate drugs under the supervision
of a board-certified qualified
psychiatrist or at less risk for forming
addictions to other substances in
adulthood or other substances generally
I think a lot of people also wonder
whether or not those kids and those
adults that take these ADHD meds become
addicted to the medications themselves
that's a bit of a tricky issue to
resolve anytime one stops taking a drug
or even tapers off a drug that's used to
treat something where they feel better
on the drug they're going to experience
two sets of effects and these two sets
of effects are often confounded with one
another one is the withdrawal effects so
the effects of removing the drug that
makes somebody feel less good than
Baseline so for instance a kid that
takes ADHD meds until their late teens
or early 20s decides they're going to
taper off they do that and they're
feeling lousy during the taper or when
they reduce their dosage to zero they're
you know foggy brain they can't focus
they feel a little bit depressed mood it
unclear whether or not those are
withdrawal symptoms or whether or not
those are the consequence of not having
the systems in their brain activated the
way that those systems were activated
before I realize that for some of you
that might seem like the same thing but
that's not necessarily the same thing
and probably the best analogy would be
something along the lines of a hangover
right if somebody drinks too much on a
given night the next morning they have a
hangover The Hangover makes them feel
lousy it's it is actually a withdrawal
from alcohol effect but then when they
recover from The Hangover they realize
that their sober State feels pretty good
it doesn't obviously feel the same as
being on alcohol but that sober state is
not a state of withdrawal okay if we
were to look at removal or tapering off
of ADHD meds there's going to be a
period of withdrawal symptoms but then
the real question is how does somebody
feel after they get through those
withdrawal symptoms so that's an
important issue to highlight now in
terms of psychosis this is a very
interesting and very important
literature sure first of all any
amphetamine whether or not it's D
amphetamine L amphetamine and also
methylphenidate for that matter Ritalin
can induce psychosis now there are a
number of different factors that are
going to predispose somebody to
psychosis having a first relative who's
had psychotic episodes either
schizophrenic episodes or bipolar
episodes is certainly a strong
predisposition
of course if an individual themselves
have had psychotic episodes that's the
strongest predisposition that one could
imagine so having a first relative with
schizophrenia or with bipolar depression
or sometimes called bipolar disorder
sometimes it's also just called bipolar
these days is going to be a strong
predisposition for psychotic episodes
made much greater
anytime one takes a sympathomimetic drug
such as amphetamine but also
methylphenidate Ritalin is going to
increase that likelihood of psychotic
episodes then comes the question of if
somebody has a psychotic episode as the
consequence of taking any of these drugs
whether or not it's been prescribed for
ADHD or not will those psychotic
symptoms go away after the person stops
taking the drug there appears to be a
divide in the literature or rather a
divide according to drug such that
people that take Ritalin methylphenidate
and have a psychotic episode often not
always but most often if they stop
taking methylphenidate The Psychotic
episode will cease
not always the case but most often times
it will cease whereas in individuals who
have a predisposition to psychosis or
even if they're not aware of a
predisposition of psychosis and they
take Adderall which as you recall is a
combination of D and L amphetamine
they can have psychotic episodes that
sometimes are very long lasting even
after the cessation of the drug and
while that might sound kind of shocking
and really scary and indeed it is scary
it perhaps shouldn't shock us that much
because if you recall D amphetamine
which there's a lot of in Adderall it's
a very potent way of increasing dopamine
and anytime you potently increase
dopamine in a person who has a
predisposition to psychotic episodes you
are shifting the whole system toward a
greater propensity for psychosis this
would also be the appropriate time to
talk about meth methamphetamine
again methamphetamine is considered an
illicit drug a drug of abuse it is
responsible for a lot of The Misfortune
and tragedy that you see on the streets
of major cities and even outside of
major cities and rural areas it has all
sorts of negative effects on health
including oral health cardiovascular
health it is neurotoxic to serotonergic
neuron so it kills serotonin neurons
that is absolutely clear it kills
dopaminergic neurons that is absolutely
clear one of the ways that
methamphetamine creates so many of the
problems that it does eating effects on
the body abuse potential addictive
potential
the fact that methamphetamine can spark
psychosis in those that have a
predisposition to psychosis but also
that it can create psychosis in
individuals who have no predisposition
to psychosis right all of this points to
methamphetamine just being a terrible
drug all around and yet if you recall
back to the beginning of the episode
there is one form of prescription
methamphetamine but its uses are
extremely narrow and it's probably best
left out of this conversation because
its uses are so so narrow in the
clinical sense I managed to talk to One
expert this is a board-certified
psychiatrist who's expert in ADHD who is
also very familiar with the psychosis
symptoms induced by methamphetamine and
by various ADHD drugs and people who
have the predisposition they made it
very clear that any of the sympathom and
medic ADHD drugs that are of the
amphetamine variety so that would be
Adderall and extended release Adderall
it'll be Pure dexedrine or any variants
that include amphetamine are going to
have higher likelihood of inducing
psychosis and people that have a
predisposition of psychosis and yet they
did assure me that at appropriately
prescribed and safe dosages that the
total incidence of psychosis in people
that take those drugs is still fairly
low and not that much greater than in
the general population although there is
an increased risk it's not that severe
and they also highlighted the fact that
methylphenidate Ritalin carries a lower
potential for inducing psychosis not
zero but a lower level of inducing
psychosis then for the amphetamine type
sympathomimetics now one exception is a
Vyvanse that long release damphetamine
that we talked about earlier there does
seem to be some things protective about
that long duration release of
damphetamine that occurs with Vyvanse
which is not to say that there's zero
abuse or addictive potential with
Vyvanse
um I was told by the same individual
that indeed they've had knowledge of
patients trying to increase the rate of
absorption of Vyvanse and release of
Vyvanse or technically of the
damphetamine in order to get more of a
high from Vyvanse as opposed to just the
extended release but they did assure me
however that Vivant seems to be
associated with fewer psychotic episodes
and less abuse and addictive potential
overall which again is not to say that
it's a perfectly safe drug but really
this just highlights the fact that the
kinetics or the time course of dopamine
and norepinephrine release that's caused
by a given drug is going to correlate
very strongly with its abuse potential
and addictive potential and its
potential to induce psychotic episodes
and this is where the discussion about
meth becomes especially relevant one of
the reasons why meth is so dangerous in
terms of its addictive potential and its
potential to induce psychotic episodes
is first of all how much dopamine it
releases again five times more than any
of the other drugs that we've been
talking about but also how fat past that
Peak comes on it's a very fast onset and
that's true whether or not people are
snorting it without their taking it
orally or especially if they inject it
intravenously
but meth because it increases dopamine
so fast into such a great degree and
then the the peak in dopamine comes down
very fast as well and it drops below the
Baseline levels of dopamine that were
present initially that's one of the
reasons why methamphetamine is so
dangerous in terms of addiction and in
terms of psychotic episodes this gets
back to a bunch of issues we've talked
about before on the huberman Lab podcast
about dopamine kinetics and I've done
two episodes on dopamine that I'll refer
you to one is called dopamine motivation
and drive which is all about dopamine
and regulating dopamine and the other
one is about optimizing dopamine it's
more of a toolkit focused episode both
those you can find at hubermanlab.com
but the general takeaway that's relevant
for what we're talking about now is that
with dopamine it's not just about the
absolute levels of dopamine that are
reached but how long lasting those
increases in dopamine are so with
vivance even though vivance is
damphetamine it's fairly potent not as
impotent as meth but fairly potent at
increasing dopamine and norepinephrine
it's a long extended release in dopamine
and norepinephrine which reduces its
overall abuse potential because it
doesn't tend to create that immediate
Euphoria and high and then crash below
Baseline
a lot of you will hear that it increases
dopamine a lot and then stays up as
translating to okay well then you're
just euphoric for 16 hours but that's
not the case when it comes to dopamine
it's an issue of How High that Peak is
and whether or not that Peak is stable
or whether or not it comes down again
and when it comes to psychotic episodes
or addictive potential it seems that any
drug or behavior that increases dopamine
very quickly and then brings dopamine
down very quickly is what sets the high
potential for addiction and abuse and
for inducing psychotic episodes so
that's why I'm talking about these two
things in parallel and now it should be
very clear why vyvance doesn't have so
much addictive and abuse potential and
has at least lower potential for
inducing psychotic episodes and it
should also be clear to you
that for people who do not have ADHD as
a child or for people that do not have
ADHD in adulthood if they were to take
any truly any of the compounds that
we're talking about thus far
methylphenidate Ritalin Adderall vivance
dexedrine and certainly methamphetamine
what we observe from neuroimaging
studies is that these people get
enormous increases in dopamine they're
not familiar with these drugs so the
increases in dopamine are just Cosmic
for them they experience a lot of
euphoria even if the dosages are low the
Euphoria is associated with a very
heightened degree of focus they've never
really felt before here what I'm talking
about is a lot of the recreational and
off prescription use of Adderall and
things like it and what we know is that
that sets in motion both a potential for
abuse and addiction to that feeling and
substance as well as a higher potential
for psycho episodes down the road okay
so put differently children who have
ADHD and are prescribed any of these
drugs
or adults who have ADHD and are
prescribed any of these drugs who take
them for some period of time are
actually at lesser risk to all of the
issues related to having chronically
elevated and greatly elevated dopamine
as a kind of first time event or as a
rare event whereas anyone who takes
these drugs without a prescription and
decides okay I want to focus more or I'm
going to use this to stay up for a
couple of days
in other words using it recreationally
or using it for quote-unquote
performance enhancement is that far
greater risk for addiction to these
substances because of the amplitude and
the time course of dopamine that results
when one takes these drugs just out of
the blue and so for that reason I really
want to caution everybody against using
any of the compounds that I've discussed
thus far unless it's been prescribed to
you by a physician for the specific
purpose of ADHD now I'm sure someone out
there is screaming from the back wait
if a kid takes these drugs because
they're prescribed them for ADHD the
very first time they take them they're
going to have a huge amplitude dopamine
response or if an adult goes in and
talks to their psychiatrist and says you
know I'm having issues with focusing in
their prescribed one of these meds for
ADHD and they take it they're going to
have a huge amplitude dopamine response
isn't that going to set in motion all
the same things that somebody who is
using these drugs recreationally would
have and indeed that's one of the
reasons why a lot of psychiatrists will
start with a very low dosage or the
lowest possible dosage to see how
somebody responds to that low dosage and
then over time might or might not
increase that dosage in fact they might
even bring it down further depending on
how sensitive somebody is to the drug
but equally important is the fact that
it is the repeated taking of that drug
by the child with ADHD or by the adult
with ADHD that actually leads to lesser
and lesser peaks in dopamine each time
which is not to say that the person
becomes entirely desensitized to the
effects of the drug but rather that the
system equilibrates through what's
called homeostatic plasticity sometimes
referred to broadly as habituation to a
drug but there are systems in the brain
and body that regulate the connections
between neurons so that if dopamine and
norepinephrine are elevated above
Baseline levels for a while the system
normalizes so that instead the
connections between neurons become
stronger and there isn't the critical
requirement for all that increase in
dopamine and norepinephrine I realize
that might sound a little bit technical
but basically what I'm saying is the
response that somebody has to taking a
drug for the first time is Far and Away
different than the response to a drug
that somebody has if they are taking the
same drug day after day after day this
gets to another issue which is not
discussed that often these days but that
is really important if you go back to
the original clinical literature on the
sympathomimetics what you'll find is
that
the original use of these
sympathomimetics to treat childhood ADHD
suggested that children not take these
drugs every single day now I'm not
recommending that kids take drug
holidays because I'm not a clinician I'm
not promoting any specific dose or
dosing regimen but in speaking again to
a psychiatrist expert in ADHD who by the
way is going to be a guest on this
podcast in the not too distant future
what he told me was that many of these
drugs were designed to be taken during
the school week for children with
weekends off or during the school year
with weekends off but then also with
vacations during the summer holidays and
that these days rarely if ever is that
the pattern of intake that these kids
are following and why that is has
interesting sociological and financial
explanations
I'm not alluding to any kind of
conspiracy here but this is an aspect of
the dosing with these drugs that has
sort of Fallen away in recent years but
I think is really interesting and it's
something that actually was supported
for the treatment of adult ADHD as well
again there is a very different
biological and neuroplastic response to
taking a drug once versus taking a drug
for say five days and then taking
weekends off to taking a drug
over and over again every single day for
a pattern of years and when exploring
the literature and preparation for this
episode I confess it was a bit dizzying
to find answers to what are the
long-term effects of taking Adderall or
what are the long-term effects of taking
Vyvanse Etc in fact most of the
literature on the long-term effects of
taking drugs to treat ADHD has focus on
methylphenidate on Ritalin there are
studies on Vyvanse and adderall and
actually those were the studies that I
will link in the show note captions
primarily because that's where most of
the interest is these days the reason
why so many of the Studies have focused
on methylphenidate on Ritalin is largely
because that was one of the first drugs
used to treat ADHD so in terms of
addressing long-term effects so kids
treated with ADHD meds those kids are
now adults and therefore can be
neuroimaged and assessed whereas a lot
of kids that have been prescribed
Adderall or Vyvanse or similar have not
yet made it to stages of life in which
we can answer that question directly
there are a few studies and I've made it
clear to include those studies in my
description of results today in
particular the result I talked about
earlier where there's an improvement in
executive function in kids that have
taken ADHD meds or adults that have
taken ADHD meds for a longer period of
time anywhere from months to years those
studies did include both Adderall and
Vyvanse and methylphenidate and again
I'll link to those studies but by and
large most of what we know about the
long-term effects of any of these drugs
has to do primarily with studies of
methylphenidate I'd like to spend a
little bit of time talking about some
compounds that are not considered
amphetamines at all but that are now
being used to treat ADHD both in
children and adults more frequently the
major drug in this category of
non-amphetamine treatments for ADHD is
modafinil which is also called by its
commercial name Provigil
there's a variance on this which is our
modafinil which goes by the brand name
Nuvigil the major difference between
modafinil and arm modafinil aside from
having a slight chemical difference is
that modafinil was released first our
modafinil is the second in the
generation of these drugs
and modafinil tends to be very expensive
that's one of the reasons why it's
prohibitive for some people to take it
can be as expensive as 25 a pill or more
to more than a thousand dollars per
month
and our modafinil tends to be far far
less expensive I've talked to a couple
experts about whether or not there are
any genuine differences between these
two drugs and they report no although
consumers of these drugs for whatever
reason whether or not it's Placebo or
not report yes there is a different when
I say Placebo I in no way mean that
these drugs are just acting as Placebo I
just mean that you know people tend to
get very attached to certain drugs and
whether or not the brand name or the
generic version works better for them
there's all sorts of lore about this in
fact there are a lot of people out there
who strongly feel that brand name
Adderall works better than generic
Adderall for them
there are a lot of people out there who
say the same thing about vivance there
are a lot of people out there who say
the same thing about Ritalin and all
sorts of drugs whether or not that's
true or not is unclear
it is clear that generic versions of
drugs can use binders and other things
that are in the pill or capsule that are
different than what the brand name
pillar capsule uses as binders to hold
the drug together and that can impact
rates of release and Metabolism Etc but
a lot of this is just Laura in fact I
went into the literature to try and find
any
real concrete support for the idea that
generic adderall is less potent or less
effective than brand name Adderall and
despite the tens of thousands of people
who will say to the contrary I could not
find any peer-reviewed published data
about that so who knows maybe it's a
belief effect as it's called maybe
there's a real difference there nowadays
modafinil and armodafinil are prescribed
for a huge range of daytime sleepiness
issues and we were talking about
narcolepsy but there are also people who
suffer from daytime sleepiness related
to dementia daytime sleepiness related
to post surgery anesthesia so there's
this thing where people have surgery and
then they come out of surgery and they
feel better for a few days but then they
find that they aren't recovering their
normal levels of wakefulness so it's
prescribed sometimes to try and get
people back into a normal state of
wakefulness it's been prescribed for a
traumatic head injury after stroke again
all of these prescribed uses have to be
carried out by a certified physician you
really don't want to start cowboying the
use of modafinil or modafinil or any
other prescription drug for that matter
I must say that in discussing all these
different drugs during today's episode I
have zero knowledge of any of these
drugs from a first-hand experience
except for our modafinil back in 2017 I
was prescribed a very very low dose of
armodafinil for jet lag for daytime
sleepiness issues really when I was
traveling overseas to give a talk so our
modafinil was given to me in a 25
milligram tablet it was advised to me
that I take a half or even a quarter of
that so I started with a quarter I am a
believer in minimal effective dose I'm
also somebody who's fairly
hypersensitive to most medication so I
took what I measured out to be five to
seven milligrams of our modafinil and
what I experienced was pretty profound
certainly it relieved any daytime
sleepiness in fact it made me feel
extremely alert for a period of about
four to six hours I can't say it was the
most comfortable State although I did
not feel as if I had racing heart or
anything of that sort I basically felt
as if I was in a narrow tunnel of
attention for that entire period one
thing I did not like about the
experience is that it was a very hard
experience to come down from there was
no crash but I found that that high
arousal State didn't taper off for many
hours later even though it was most
heightened for four hours I would say
anywhere from 8 to 12 hours later I
still felt like I was you know blinking
once every four minutes or so and I've
certainly been accused on this this
podcast and at other times of blinking
to seldom to my knowledge I don't have
ADHD I've never been prescribed ADHD
meds I've never been tested for ADHD I
don't think I have ADHD and yet taking
our modafinil certainly increased my
levels of attention but at least by that
one experience it's not something that I
would want to repeat again I certainly
would not want to be in that state for
learning new material when I sit down to
research a podcast or research papers in
my lab or forage for information or
learn from people or books or lectures
or podcasts I want to be in a state of
alertness but calm where I can really
consider the ideas where I can script
things out by hand I'm a big believer in
writing things out by hand to remember
them later drawing little diagrams I
would not want to be in the state that
even that very low dose of our modafinil
put me in in order to learn and I should
mention that both modafinil and
armodafinil are associated with a good
number of side effects if they don't
agree with you or if the dosage is too
high things like decreased appetite
people get a run nose headache there's
this instance of skin rashes in fact one
of the reasons why modafinil and arm
modafinil aren't more broadly prescribed
is that there's a very rare skin
condition in which people who have taken
certain drugs not just modafin or arm
modafinil have developed these very
severe
burn type blisters and in some cases
this can be fatal this is again very
rare and it was observed in at least one
patient who took modafinil as part of a
trial for modafinil as a treatment for
ADHD it's called Stevens-Johnson
syndrome please if you are squeamish to
images of skin abrasions and lesions and
things of that sort please don't look it
up on the internet unless you're able to
handle that and maybe not at all but the
point here is that
one of the reasons that modafinil in our
modafinil are not more widely prescribed
for ADHD and that it's still only
prescribed off label
is that Stephen Johnson syndrome was
flagged as kind of a potential risk
although the ADHD
specialist that I spoke to are somewhat
frustrated with that because they insist
that the frequency of this syndrome that
causes the skin rash that's sometimes
fatal is no more frequent in those that
took modafinil in this trial than with
other drugs that have been approved so
this gets into all sorts of issues
around what drugs make it to approval
and which ones don't and as we know
modafinil and or modafinil are already
being prescribed in the general
population for other things this was
dealing specifically with the question
of whether or not it should be
prescribed in kids with ADHD and
certainly I am a proponent of exerting
Extreme Caution when thinking about
which drugs should be approved for the
treatment of anybody but especially kids
and to round out our discussion of drugs
used for the treatment of ADHD that fall
into let's call it the atypical category
right the typical category being
Adderall Vyvanse methylphenidate and
things of that variety the less typical
would be modafinil armodafone proprion
Wellbutrin
and so forth
the last in this category of atypical is
guanfacine guanfacine is an interesting
compound it's a compound that was
developed to lower blood pressure and
indeed it does lower blood pressure and
it is an alpha 2A Agonist Alpha 2A being
a receptor for norepinephrine so
guanfacine is a non-stimulant medication
to treat ADHD and it's also used to
treat some other conditions as well that
is only working on the noradrenergic
system it is not tapping into the
dopamine system but all the other stuff
that we talked about is really ramping
up dopamine and norepinephrine
guanfacine is only increasing
norepinephrine and it's doing so by what
we say agonizing or stimulating one
particular aspect of the noradrenergic
system and that's the alpha 2A system
what's interesting about guanfacine is
that it has a bunch of Pathways that it
activates that feed back onto the
autonomic nervous system to dampen down
the activation of the sympathetic
nervous system so whereas most of what
we talked about today are
sympathomimetics they tend to make us
more ramped up more aroused and alert
guanfacine is doing the opposite and as
a consequence it's not prescribed that
often because a lot of times when people
take guanfacine it either has no effect
on ADHD symptoms or it tends to make
people feel very sleepy however there's
a small subset of individuals by about
five to ten percent of people that try
it including kids that do get some
significant relief from their ADHD
symptoms and they seem to tolerate
guanfacine better than they're
tolerating some of the other drugs that
we've talked about up until now the way
guanfacine works is also really
interesting you're now familiar with the
locus ceruleus this little packet or we
call it a nucleus of neurons in the back
of the brain that release norepine
different at other sites in the brain
and they're going to be those Alpha 2A
receptors that guanfacine works on and
stimulates lots of different places in
the brain related to increasing salience
and relevance of particular stimuli that
we see and that we need to attend to it
appears that guanfacine can activate the
prefrontal cortical networks in ways
that are above their normal Baseline so
that's good so improvements in executive
function that Orchestra or teacher-like
function we talked about before and can
increase the efficacy of that output
from Locus ceruleus and what that seems
to do is increase the coordinated firing
of locus ceruleus neurons with
prefrontal cortex so in many ways it's
acting like a fine-tuning of that
Orchestra conductor operation that is so
valuable in teaching these brain
circuits during childhood of how to
attend to one thing and ignore
everything else so this is one reason
why guanfacine is now approved not just
for adults with ADHD but it's primarily
used in kids age 6 to 17 years old for
the treatment of ADHD again with the
hope that these kids can take the drug
and these circuits can learn how to
focus and how to
attend to certain things and limit
impulsivity and hyperactivity
and then perhaps come off the drugs
although sometimes again people have to
stay on them indefinitely the other
thing about guanfacine is that because
it lowers blood pressure and it has this
effect of kind of dampening down overall
sympathetic arousal sometimes it is
prescribed in conjunction with other
ADHD meds so yes there are kids out
there and adults out there who are
taking Adderall and guanfacine where
they're taking Vyvanse and guanfacine
and this is where it starts to get into
drug cocktails and a bunch of other
things that gets everybody a little bit
uncomfortable I think because the idea
of taking one drug to dampen down the
side effects of another drug and to
offset things and compensate you know is
getting towards what's called poly
pharmacology
and uh you know I think it's
understandable that people be concerned
about that and yet
again in reviewing this with some of the
experts on ADHD there do seem to be a
certain category of children out there
and adults who really struggle with the
standard ADHD meds and in that case
guanfacine has provided a certain number
of these individuals tremendous relief
one note about guanfacine in no way
shape or form am I encouraging anyone
who's not prescribed guanfacine to take
it but should you know someone who's
taking guanfacine off label in order to
improve their focus or enhance any
aspect of their biology or psychology
please let them know that it has a
profound effect on lowering the
tolerance for alcohol such that even
small amounts of alcohol can lead to
really serious problems and even
potentially death so that's a very
serious warning with guanfacine so today
we discussed a lot of different
compounds for the treatment of ADHD and
it now should become clear what the
general themes of those compounds is the
general theme is that they tend to
increase overall levels of arousal and
wakefulness which leads to decreased
levels of hyperactivity impulsivity and
focus and on the face of it that might
seem counter-intuitive raise arousal to
reduce hyperactivity and impulsivity
indeed that's the case because these
compounds because they act on
neuromodulator systems like dopamine and
norepine epinephrine are effective in
creating neuroplasticity they change the
strength of the connections in the
neural circuits of the brain that lead
to states of heightened focus and
reduced impulsivity and reduced
hyperactivity so we talked about the
different mechanisms by which the
different medications for ADHD
accomplish this both the typical sort
like methylphenidate and adderall and
vivance and some of the atypical
compounds that are now being used in
addition such as modafinil or modafinil
guanfacine and Wellbutrin and where
possible I tried to highlight both the
short and long-term effects of these
various compounds and I try to address
some of the major concerns about these
compounds most notably the question of
why are we putting so many kids on
amphetamine and what is the long-term
consequence of that and throughout
today's episode I tried to highlight
both the immediate and long-term
benefits but also the immediate and
long-term risks that can exist with
these compounds certainly when taken
without a prescription recreationally
there is a real risk for abuse and
addiction as well as even a risk for
psychotic episodes but also the risks
that accompany long-term use of these
drugs in people with ADHD and yet it is
also clear that not treating the
symptoms of ADHD carry significant risk
as well and what's very clear from the
scientific and clinical literature and
is covered in a significant amount of
detail in the episode that I did about
ADHD which you can find at
hubermanlab.com is that combinations of
drug treatments and behavioral protocols
seem to surpass either drug treatments
or behavioral protocols alone speaking
to the tremendous importance of
combining multiple methodologies when
treating ADHD and working with a
board-certified psychiatrist who really
understands ADHD and is really up to
date on all the latest scientific and
clinical literature
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can also leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast
if you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or suggestions about
guests you'd like me to include on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube I do
read all the comments not so much on
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep
hormone support as well as Focus the
huberman Lab podcast is proud to have
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to see the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so it's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already follow me on social
media I am huberman lab on all platforms
so that's Facebook LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram and on all those platforms I
post about science and science related
tools some of which overlaps with the
content of the huberman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content on the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a monthly newsletter in which we
distill down the essential points of
particular podcasts and we list Out tool
kits such as toolkits for sleep toolkits
for neuroplasticity toolkits for
optimizing dopamine and on and on all of
which is available at zero cost you
simply go to hubermanlab.com go to the
menu scroll down to newsletter and
Supply your email we do not share your
email with anybody thank you for joining
me for today's discussion all about
pharmaceutical interventions for the
treatment of ADHD and last but certainly
not least thank you for your interest in
science
[Music]